you're about to watch is one of our
recorded American tour shows but if
you're in Europe right now there is
another tour going on right now which
you can get tickets for that's right
trash taste is coming to Europe if you
guys have seen before we've announced
that we are doing a Europe tour in
September of 2023 tickets are still
available for some of the shows so get
them while they are there links down in
the description below so we hope you
enjoy and if you want to see us in
person well looking forward to seeing
you guys in Europe
[Music]
your birthday
stuff what do we get a 50 000 camera to
eat a burrito I couldn't see it the
lighting's terrible uh mine tour
schedule plus I would wake up I uh I
have a person I just listened to it yes
are you guys sick of each other yet
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome to the stage
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
Los Angeles what is up
how are you guys doing tonight
guys this show is all about energy so
you're gonna have to be screaming at
non-stop okay yeah
good good it is uh what is a Tuesday
today it's a Tuesday night it's gonna be
Saturday energy baby right
thank you
know you know let's let's test out how
loud you guys can go all right wait wait
wait is there any one-piece fans in the
ground
all right all right guys so when I say
the one piece you say is real
are you guys ready
okay okay
the one piece
we got much higher
I think you guys are just here for
anything right
can I get a chair if La sucks
can I get a tree if you think that LAX
is a great Airport
factually incorrect yeah can I get a
tree if one piece sucks
hey you know what hey yo what
that was three beats and you fought for
all three of them
it's nice to be back here we've
basically gone around the entire us now
yeah we're back in la oh my God yeah
and uh guys we're glad to say our
opinion on America has not changed at
all literally the same
literally the same listen every time
you've got anywhere in America they're
like
you do Regional differences are huge
it's like really there's like one
different Source in a Subway it's crazy
and it's like what how is that you're
our national identity that you have
different fast food chains yeah every uh
every state that we've gone to on this
tour the you know the fans have come out
to us and being like yo have you checked
out that that local you know that one
local restaurant that you should
definitely try before you go you know
nine times out of ten we go to try it
[__] booger isn't it
another version of
a burger or something that that destroys
our digestive system yeah is there any
state with a local salad dish because uh
we're still waiting guys we're still
waiting oh doctors in Japan are very
afraid I don't want to think about it
man I honestly don't yes but this show
is all about getting you guys as
involved as possible hell yeah so if we
make so if we make a good take please
cheer if we make a bad take please boo
okay otherwise we're gonna think it's
all good taste yeah you know what
wait wait
[Applause]
you know you know let's let's test this
out actually because we've gone around
all the all of the states now and we've
made our personal mission to find out
our favorite local Burger chain right
Joey what's your favorite local Burger
chain uh
uh Whataburger
[Applause]
literally not edible it's just spicy
ketchup that's all they have they have
nothing else yeah
what about you got so I don't know if
anyone's ever been to the Midwest but
mine's got to be Culver's man
oh wow wow I've seen some Midwestern
representation but you know we have four
people from the Midwest over there
somewhere I've tried every single burger
in America basically at this point yeah
I'm just gonna say it in and out is
still the best
you guys you guys figured it out
you just did it congrats that's yours
[Applause]
was actually trash it was straight out
of trash
okay I like this energy this is good
we're gonna keep this up all show okay
guys yeah
good good yeah but um we have a full
show lined up for you guys and uh you
know there are two things we ask at uh
every single trash Case tour show and uh
the first one is of course we all hope
you have a [__] awesome time tonight
because that's what we came to do right
hell yeah
and the second one is uh you know it I
think it goes without saying that it is
a real massive achievement that we
managed to get this many weaves to touch
grass at the same time
truly man an achievement and you know
hopefully if you're a fan of trash taste
uh then you know you'll be seeing us on
your phone screens laptop screens every
single week so just for tonight guys you
guys came all the way out here to see us
live so the only thing we ask you guys
to do is to just put your phones away
yeah just for the night yeah don't
actually worry because this show is
actually being filmed guys hi
so so I actually get to say this and uh
mean it
guys
this episode of trash taste was filmed
in front of a live studio audience
wait wait why are you bullying her what
the hell
it's like I paid money to boot tonight
God damn it
yeah so again since we are getting this
particular show filmed you'll see it on
YouTube hopefully later uh you know we
just asked you know we want you guys to
be involved with the shows as much as
possible right as involved as we are
with the show but I'll do you guys a
solid all right for the next 15 seconds
you can take as many photos as you want
[Applause]
all right put your phones away
no more ass
no more for the rest of the show
if I see if I see another phone
[Applause]
another phone during the show I will
personally come down and be very angry
you know you know what you know what
Joey's gonna do
he's going to call the manager guys I
will
don't make me do it I will call the
manager
but
yeah
foreign
but in true trash taste fashion we're
gonna have three segments in the show
guys and each of us are going to host a
different segment starting with this
beautiful man right here
that's so kind of you that's so kind
thank you
[Music]
all right I'm glad to know that I don't
need to do anything to get you guys
hyped right you guys already hyped right
[Applause]
right well well well this is a rather
personal game and it's personal favorite
of mine because it's all about how much
maybe you guys know about us you might
have heard of parasocial relationships
before right guys you've heard of them
you're like yeah I [__] love them yes
I only have friends with the screen
so you know obviously the the podcast
has so many hours nearly approaching one
piece probably when this is out after
two years of editing we will have more
hours than one piece that's scary
I know I know is there anyone here who
has watched every episode of trash taste
and every episode of One Piece loser
loser lying you're lying you're lying
you're lying you're lying you're lying
I'm proud of you for touching grass guys
I I know this must be a first I'm so
proud of you guys we're totally friends
I see him he's right there we're friends
we're friends right guys
no we're not not with you everyone else
but you
all right
sorry about that you seem kind of
satisfied
so we want to make a game that would
kind of rewards your knowledge of us
because you've probably sat through far
too much trash taste right
so our first game is going to be the
parasocial game
[Music]
now as you know we have we have so many
props on trash taste some of them
unfortunately we couldn't bring because
your government hates giving out Visas
so instead we have the next best thing
for trash box could
we want to bring trash box come with us
but we couldn't right one this is a
weird thing to bring on a plane
so we have his American cousin guys yes
that's a big boy this is one Texas
barbecue later
in here is going to be questions about
me and we're going to test you the
audience your knowledge of me and see if
you guys know me maybe better than my
own friends do no no you guys don't know
me better than them right
you do
well one person was really really
confident right there but I know
everything about you how this is gonna
work is I'm gonna pull out a prompt it's
gonna be a question like what is my
favorite burger in the U.S obviously I'd
say
right so what we're going to do is
they're going to write down the answer
on their iPad they're going to lock it
in someone's gonna put their hands up in
the audience and a runner will go around
with a microphone and select someone at
random that person is then going to
answer for you the audience yeah yeah
sometimes I'm glad that one guy has
really all confidence in the audience
there
sometimes you guys are weirdly too good
at this
sometimes you guys are trolling
um sometimes people answer who haven't
watched trash taste which is great
you're really helping the team out there
you guys ready
all right I'll get the first question
then all right let's do it all right
what's the first question corner get in
there real good Jesus
okay did you really have to double cheek
them 10 minutes into the show
I'm sorry I'm sorry audience I get to
get two into it all right you don't have
the first question
[Applause]
all right now if you know the answer
don't shout it out because you'll help
them too and I have a feeling that a lot
of you are going to know the answer to
this one all right okay so just zip it
all right you can laugh that's fine
what is my favorite nickname for myself
wow I wonder what this one could be
Connor no one knows this right no one
has any idea right
I wish I wish I could be him
well uh yeah I'm gonna write down my
answer they're going to write down their
answers they're going to throw it to the
audience if you know the answer but
yeah and you're going to answer for that
yeah you don't have to write it down
Connor we've already written nails down
we already know this one's I'll write it
down
[__] I broke the iPad already
how do I break this
there is a rotating head of you in the
car
why is there a Conor head in the Crowd
Oh you're back again oh my God this is
what
oh my God
you got it down oh wait there's a joey
head right at the back as well oh hell
yeah
all right that's scary you just looked
in your answer yeah yeah we got it I've
looked to my answer who thinks I know
the answer to this what question huh you
think so now
So You Think You Know It
all right let's see okay so introduce
yourself before you say the answer let
us know who you are let the crowd know
all right hello my name is Faye hello
hello
so I think the answer is monkey I think
the answer is monkey okay okay would you
guys think you think it might be monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys like that a little a little too
much right all right God what do you
think the answer is going to be then
it's a great answer audience yeah I mean
that is obviously the obvious answer but
Conor's a gamer I think Conor's gonna
try and game the system if it's too
obvious and uh there's one thing that I
think Connor is uh better known as
sit down London no
God damn it why do you have to be here
I can't believe it the British Ludwig
and the American Ludwig are both God
I don't have his I didn't put all my
skill points in Charisma like him I
can't do it
all right all right Joey what's your
answer then yeah I mean you know I
really thought about it as well and uh
that I mean you know obviously great
answer but um uh you know I I wish
I'm just kidding I put my mind
I'm just kidding I like how you've done
the the appropriate spelling I will
accept no other type of spelling than
this one
even though anyone who can speak English
will tell you that clearly says Monk
can I tell a story can I can I I haven't
told the story before sure um I used to
have a RuneScape account when I was like
10.
and I was so I was so bad at spelling
and I was obsessed with Donkey Kong that
I spelled donkey without a y and that
was my name was donkey donkey Man 2 or
something
it was not the best at spelling okay I
failed all right somebody is right
though okay do you think it's you the
audience
you think it might be gone
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got the same answer as you the
answer is here
[Applause]
well
I think sometimes images can speak
louder than words don't you agree so I
thought I would I'd do a little drawing
to show my answer
congratulations you've got a point
wait wait okay okay can you clarify so
so that is that is a monkey right not
Ludwig right that's a bunch
that's a monkey that's a monkey all
right
all right let's do it all right let's do
it all right let's get it
all right here we go
all right
audience what is one video game I can't
live without oh easy easy it's my the
one video game I love more than anything
over shut the [__] up
[Applause]
no it's uh you could play as a monkey
it's got to be the best game
it's uh it's a Valerian right corner you
love Valerie
you won't stop talking about how much
you love valorant
attention yo you're talking to the wrong
person man I'm I'm right here man I'm
right here
[Applause]
[Music]
remember it's one game I can't live
without not necessarily my favorite game
of all time but it's a game I can't live
without okay it is not raid [__]
Shadow Legends okay
yeah
maybe if they sponsored this tour I
don't know
we're bleeping that out in the Final Cut
they're not getting any free promo okay
you guys logged in your answers yeah
I've logged in my answer audience who
thinks you know the answer hands up if
you think you know the answer
oh there's people up there I had no idea
I think you guys got to make some noise
[Applause]
all right
uh sorry to tell you but the person's
dance step down here so they're gonna
she'll come up though she'll come up
she'll come up sorry
sorry all right
you should have booked tickets earlier
seriously thank you thank you for coming
and thank you for buying merch and I
really appreciate it thanks guys so
sorry All Right audience where are we at
Jesse are we here hi introduce yourself
hi
hi it's Amber hello
I'm nice to meet you too what do you
think the answer might be I'm thinking
team fight tactics
are you calling me out why are you
calling me out
damn
I'm addicted to that
should I tell the story about how I okay
so yeah yeah tell the story so uh I was
10 LP off hitting Diamond as you all
know in Game of terms very cool uh for
you non-games now man out there that
mean he said he was about to win I was
about to be a big Giga Chad all right I
was about to win and I was in the hotel
room I thought you know what I'm going
to celebrate my win with a bath so I
started running the bath uh before I
started playing the game and I was I was
killing it and just as I hit diamond
on the door
and I step up
oh my hotel room is [__] flooded
and my entire hallway is flooded I open
up the door all of the hallways flooded
in 30 minutes one game a league that's
why you should never play league okay
ever
and uh can we just appreciate that
Connor was in Colorado for less than 24
hours and he already broke something
yeah so I don't know if any if there's
any lawyers here in the statute of
limitations of flooding four hotel rooms
but hit me up after the show would
appreciate it
I have not been charged yet fingers
crossed okay great answer team fight
tactics God what do you think the answer
might be yeah that's actually terrifying
because normally normally Conor has a
lot of games that he publicly plays but
one thing that he's been playing a lot
is of course this which League team
fight tactics you know different game
okay okay gonna okay okay okay okay
but he's been playing nothing but this
not at all I swear to God guys I've been
playing Team fight tactics it's a
completely different game it has got
nothing to do with LOL yes it's in the
same game loading thing
it is copium okay
uh what I'm addicted what am I supposed
to do
it's not it's not cocaine it's blow okay
all right Cherry what do you think the
answer is um yeah wow um well I wasn't
expecting this uh same brain cell am I
right holy [__]
yo come here man come here come here
why of course of course listen I hate
myself I mean this is the correct answer
yeah I don't care what you put Connor
just likes to suffer he's uh he's got
Stockholm syndromes with all his games
yeah
listen I I really hate myself but not
not that
no no why are we cheering no
oh we're cheering four or against League
of Legends
[Applause]
got it good listen
yeah I'm addicted to TFT I'll admit it
but the one game that I love the most
come on guys you know this yeah you know
it it's jump King give it to me yes yes
I'm addicted I can't get out help I hope
they don't release any more DLC please
stop
I do love it though it's really fun you
guys are wrong there's you don't know me
we're not friends but there's no way you
actually enjoy this I refuse to believe
that you actually enjoy this corner yeah
I do actually enjoy jumping it is very
satisfying it's fun it's fun guys right
[Applause]
yo as Connor is a captor to three
different uh
all the games I like do hurt me it's
just
all these answers just look like a
therapy session man
where did it all start sit down
which one was the first one his name is
yasua all right you guys ready to the
next question
all right let's get one
what'd you say
shut the [__] up
[Applause]
dramatic pause
what is one thing I'd bring to a
deserted island or desert island I keep
I always say deserted I always want to
say dessert Island what's wrong with me
dessert what's one thing I would bring
to a desert island isn't that the next
one-piece Arc so Island
I have uh I have entered this on the
podcast I'm a liar don't listen to me it
will be a different answer yeah we've
said this we've talked about this on an
episode uh do I remember what you said
no I think do you guys remember what he
said I think this is I think this might
I think this might have appeared in a
show before as well but we've I uh oh my
God
I'm
okay okay I I think I know
all right I know Connor all right you
guys locked in your answers yep yeah
I've walked in my answer I've got sweaty
writing who thinks I know the answer
wait wait who actually who remembers
when we talked about this on trash taste
does anyone remember what answers we put
down on trash taste wait wait wait wait
don't say anything I think I answered
this at the other La show okay if you
remember it go ahead don't tell them do
not tell them
all right
do you know the answer how confident are
you stare into the giant camera tell
them the answer do you want the meme or
the serious answer the meme obviously
okay all right introduce yourself
oh hey hey guys I'm Quentin Hello Connor
hello what do you think I would bring to
me to a desert island uh well as we all
know uh it's going to be the singular
copy of mother knows press
foreign
[Music]
sir you think I'm gonna bring a DVD copy
of mother knows breast
through a desert island
[Applause]
not even a DVD player just the the DVD
case all right gone what do you think
I'm gonna put okay number one how is
Connor gonna play mothers no breasts on
a deserted island is he is he is he just
okay he's gonna he's just gonna look
look my guy let me tell you there's one
thing that Connor loves more than mother
knows breast all right
and it's this
he's gonna see this and he's going to
get an ego Chris no you would whine so
much
what do you mean there's no five-star
hotel on this island
where am I going to sleep
foreign
don't worry we're cutting that out of
the video so it doesn't hear yeah they
were they were chanting loser
[Applause]
all right
I'm gonna tell you now it's not what I
put down just in case it wasn't obvious
no that's not what you'd put down
because this is what you put down
if there's one thing Connor loves more
than the affability of a certain Chris
it's a clean [__]
[Applause]
times you need that right guys right
luckily you can buy swipe now guys get
swiped right
[Applause]
all right he's Chris and mother knows
brushes but like Connor's three loves in
life man no okay there's only two lobs
there all right let's be honest
like the water you go to the edge you
know
no
why are you guys like ew
all right okay well
somebody is right do you guys think it's
them
you guys think it's you foreign
give yourself a round of applause I'm
bringing it
also are you kidding me is it wildly
impractical yes but I'm [__] already I
may as well enjoy something oh
also also can I just say Connor why do
you write like a serial killer like what
is that
I just you know I haven't a lot of time
I gotta see you know it's like the
Zodiac Killer [__] like what I can
barely read that I Hey listen this is
childhood trauma first
but listen it's like you know when you
go to GameStop it's like a 10 year old
you're like I just want to see the the
game case it's enough I just want to see
the back that's enough that'll get me
back that's how I feel with it he's
ready for the next question God damn it
all right
okay and again don't say the answer if
you know it right don't help them out
okay
what is the first thing I do in the
morning
no don't say it don't say any
all right
don't answer don't give them any help I
don't want them to get it I want you to
win
uh
uh well unfortunately I don't sleep with
you so
every day do you have something that you
do every day Joe uh Connor yes
[Laughter]
correct answer
[Applause]
um
[__] you know I was gonna say this all
right it is worth the same shirt that is
semi-correct it's not gonna be that
because you just said it and I can't put
that down now
all right you guys you guys talked in
your answers Juju do you have an answer
that you do every day yeah okay okay who
thinks I know the answer hands up
who thinks they know
oh
you're like please I'm dying I want to
answer something
where are we our idea here hello
introduce yourself
[Music]
hello Lee
what do you think the answer might be
what what is one thing I do every day
well like any other normal human being
on this Earth you wake up in the morning
look yourself in the mirror and scream
at yourself
foreign
I thought that was just like some
Patrick Bateman like [__] like meme
thing that you just said sometimes
sometimes you know I mean there's a time
there's always a time for it right guys
right right
[Applause]
gonna do it every time I go to L.A I'm
like all right
awful awful Apple just get rid of it
all right you ready well what are your
answers what do you put down guys I
didn't put that because I had to just
take a stab in the dark and as the man
who would bring mother's nose mother
knows breast through a deserted island
clearly he must do this the first thing
in the morning
ukulele clearly there is no other answer
don't cheat stop
[Applause]
why would you cheer for that
do you guys do this every day
foreign
how do you get [__] done
you don't okay well that that explains
why you watch One Piece and trash taste
thank you very much
all right Joey what do you think the
answer is
um yeah wow
[Applause]
do you think so little of me
you know your nickname is monkey
so but he's not just jacking off all the
time
yeah
yo Joey Joey I felt man I felt it man we
didn't even scripture same brain saw
right here
oh my God so this is correct all right
this is the only correct answer this is
the only correct answer I don't have the
stamina for that
looks like you haven't gone through your
training art yet
all right all right all right there is
one thing that I do every day guys right
and it's very important because you know
it's how you tell you the day started
like what else are you gonna do
obviously I look in the mirror and I
shout
this
yes
yes good answer
now with now it's just confirmed to me
with that handwriting and your answer I
think you're a serial killer
no like I think you're actually Patrick
Bateman I watched Patrick Bateman shorts
whatever whatever I said on my Tick Tock
I'm like I got time oh my god
listen have you guys tried this it works
you genuinely feel hyped yeah you've
tried it yes you have that's why you did
it
that's why you answered it you know you
know it works do my neighbors absolutely
hate it yes 100
but luckily is anyone else in the
audience actually do this
okay not as many as I can I hope not as
many as I'd hoped I would have liked a
bit more there
they are all on a watch list right now
yeah all right all right guys we have
one final question are you guys ready
he's ready
[Applause]
let's do it all right all right all
right what is it corner I don't even
know why you put this in
what is my worst trash taste take what
is the worst take what do you mean oh my
God
none I got it I got it I got it wait
wait
I gotta say no more why would you even
why are you lucky I know the answer
there do it wait wait Connor we have we
have to pick one one take you to think
one of your takes if you think what I
think is the worst answer right worst
take don't bother I just write down the
correct answer
why are you saying too many I hear you
you know there's not a lot of us here
all right
I I oh this is so hard I really I got
how did you immediately go I immediately
thought of one all right hold on I got
to think about this for a second or not
God I I feel like Doctor Strange is
going through the Six Million
possibilities right now having to choose
the correct one all right come on I have
way less worse takes than these guys
right
all right you think that's funny you
think it's funny people to put me okay
it's pretty funny it's pretty funny
all right who thinks I know the answer
who thinks I know the answer
no no one else wanna no no no no all
right got it right here
all right
all right stand up I want you to stand
up and tell me my worst time okay hello
hi my name is Juliet hello Juliet and I
think your worst take is that a bear
could easily kill you more than a deer
yeah
you know what I'd completely forgotten
about that tank actually which just
shows how many takes he has listen to
that Nimble they're fast they're Nimble
they can [__] you up you've seen videos
of deers being launched in people's cars
just Tara you think bears do that no
they're like I'm coming please let me
hear you like that
there's no deer spray this past spray
there's nothing we can do to combat them
we do we do eat them sometimes but don't
worry about that
all right all right audience oh yeah you
already said it oh my God lose my mind
all right and what did you put God all
right it was it was tough picking just
one no no and you know what Connor says
a lot of bullshits but sometimes he says
[__] that is just objectively wrong
like objectively and this is one of them
like
why would they say poisoning in the name
legit scientists are crying after you
said that dude it's like all that
research for this [__] idiot to be
like
but I'll tell you another really really
bad take that you said that I'm
definitely I'm certain this crowd will
agree with it's this one no
no
no no I know there's people here who
also hate oranges right
[Applause]
you're in the you're we're in the wrong
state for this guy we're in California
baby it sucks orange juices yeah hell
yeah like I'm sorry let's go
could I have this can I can you throw it
to me throw it to me for the orange the
orange
it's where it belongs
no no
it's awful no don't eat
he's gonna eat it
[Applause]
I better tastes awful awful it's
delicious
we did it California we did it
generally this is delicious this is
sweet as [__] this is this is good stop
complimenting the oranges no one cares
listen listen
there is one obvious answer to what I
think my worst take is right
obviously I think none of them are bad
oh [__] off none of them are bad
why why would I think that
[Music]
oh oh go on go and have your oranges
they suck
[Music]
and uh so none of you get points nobody
gets points that is
how did you how did you make a take that
is worse than all three of these other
takes
I was gonna say I couldn't I didn't
think you could get a take more
objectively wrong than the food
poisoning one but I think we found one
right now there it is right there on top
left all right guys that wraps up the
first game boys
you guys want to know the scores
do you guys are under the scores
God
zero oh
[Applause]
Joey
one
[Applause]
audience
three
[Applause]
three I mean don't get me wrong
[Music]
don't get me wrong guys that's awesome
but it's also [__] terrifying listen
I'm glad someone remembered the answer
from the LA show they should have
remembered too right
friends also I think
all right well you know what this means
guys right that means that both of them
because they lost to you have to do a
punishment yes
bring out the punishment wheel yes
oh my God I don't want to look at this
wheel right now Joey Joey Joey you wanna
you wanna go first you want to spin the
wheel first sure
I love how instead of Among Us it's
Among Us
which one which one do you guys want
them to land on
I do not want to see little baby man
ever in my life I've done my time all
right all right all right well we ready
to spin the wheel
all right here we go three two one spin
the wheel
oh
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
this is the worst person to have your
fate in joined should we should make
Jerry suffer
I want to throw some I want to see maybe
should I should I pick a manga
all right
do you guys want to see Joey in the
humongous suit
Joey go get your manga suit I will I
will remember this corner
this you guys are gonna love this we
didn't have this last time the LA shows
this is good this is by far the most
suffering of the punishments for sure
and this is something that we didn't
plan because what happened is we just
walked in a Walmart to run one random
day and luckily it was Halloween guys so
there were there were a lot of costumes
to choose from
which which punishment do you not want
to do next God I'm curious I do not want
to do little baby man I do not want to
do little baby man no no no no
I've done that punishment on camera
already guys you can see it
guys it's up to the wheel it's not up to
you we've got to wait for our boy to
come out first maybe he's getting a
little shy
that is a good punishment that's an
excellent punishment Joey should watch
Arcane right guys
[Applause]
you should go check up on him he might
be a little show I'll go check out
something back there she's shy he's
almost ready oh
guys he's a little shy can we get him
can we get a joey chant Joe wait Joey
Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey
[Applause]
[Music]
did we buy a 40 among this thing and
think [__] it put it in the show yes yes
we did I don't know about you guys but
I'm feeling mighty Saucy right now
it will don't share that guys that was
awful
[Music]
[Applause]
in the meantime gone should we spin the
wheel all right guys we spin the wheel
for God thank you
all right guys three two one spin the
wheel
oh
[Music]
banana wait wait why am I getting your
punishment going on no no this should be
your punishment go backstage go get your
new album It's time for God to be a true
Georgia fan
oh he's inflated now oh he's getting
power
[Applause]
oh my god did you guys enjoy the first
round though yeah you enjoyed it
it's good it's good God are you ready
is he ready is he ready is he being shy
you want me to know the trend guys oh no
he's coming out all right
welcome your new banana
[Applause]
[Music]
God damn
so I just had to take another delicious
bite of the orange guys
[Applause]
what are you ready for the second game
well I am your host for the second game
and guys
if you watch Trash taste you may know
that we talk about America a lot
sometimes correctly a lot of the times
incorrectly
[Applause]
guys guys we already started the game
yet guys come on
but we thought we test our knowledge of
America and Americans with our second
game trash days versus America
[Applause]
[Music]
now hopefully you guys answered the QR
code that was on screen earlier because
we're going to be using your answers and
these boys are going to have to guess
the most popular answer for each
question
where's my store yeah it's a turn turn
right turn ready all right that place
here Bud's here I know you're on okay
we're good
all right I'm good I'm I'm gonna stand
here for just a second just how are you
feeling Connor not good this isn't weird
I don't know I want to be in between
this this go over there get away stop
looking at me at that get away from me I
want to answer the questions about
America okay
like you've become a stand to user now
corner
this is
this is literally the meme of the stand
the stand user will try to blend in the
stand user
all right tell them about the game God
but all of the answers you put down
they're going to have to try and guess
and if they get the most popular answer
they get Five Points then Four Points
then three points then two points then
one point now if they say the answer and
it's on the board you're going to hear
this sound
[Music]
that was so dramatic on these speakers
oh my God yes but if they say an answer
and it's not on the board you're going
to hear this sound
that is the lowest res YouTube sound
file we could download that is uh
literally the first answer that goes on
Google search if you search buzzer
sounds buzzer.mp3 free download
all right we're gonna budget here right
guys
look are you guys ready
all right swell
the first question is name one thing
America does better than anywhere else
and uh we ask you guys for this answer
so uh if you don't like the answers you
only have yourselves to blame guys
[Applause]
you can go first listen I've I'm
practically American at this point I've
spent most
why would you boo that
you speak my language
[Music]
[Applause]
listen
beans and toast is good all right [__]
you
I know America is so well listen the
reason why we we beans on territories
because if if our food was as good as
yours dude we'd be [__] right
and that's why I'm putting obesity
that's my answer
I it's been on the board a few times and
I think that you guys would put obesity
on the board as well
I've got these guys did you guys put a
BC on the board
what the [__] all right
all right let's find out then is obesity
on the board
you Liars you absolute Liars see I know
you better than you know yourself
awful stuff all right Among Us can't
take you seriously at that
the [__] did you say to me it's I can
hear your voice but my brain is not
associating it with this Among Us stop
well um let's see what else what else
are you guys good at
let me let me think about this for a
second
well Thomas said that's why you bought
your standstill Connor said obesity
so in correlation with that answer
I'm gonna say
food
how would you cheer for that and not
obesity huh
huh yeah they kind of go hand in hand
guys come on
do you guys like your food
is food on the list
it is it is now let's go through the
answers and
uh I gotta say guys what the [__] oh
because you knocked your stroll over
something's your dummy thing and I can't
help her because I'll lead you again
there we go there you go
all right there we go all right I gotta
ask guys before I reveal number five
I've got to ask you guys all right
do you uh do you have any faith in
yourselves guys
because at number five of what you think
you do better than anyone else in the
world is
being stupid
foreign
this is not something to be proud of
guys
no no stop cheering
why
are you guys good
okay yeah clearly not but you may be
wondering what is it that can beat
stupidity
of course it is
obesity
only number four it's only number four
we can get higher next time let's pop
those numbers all right these are rookie
numbers
stop no
we've got to monetize this on YouTube
Jerry
but at number three you guys put
freedom
[Applause]
nice guys guys you know you know other
countries have freedom as well right
guys
yeah but do they do it better than
America though
[Applause]
that means
you invented free we had it first we can
we let you have it
listen after what you did to T I don't
think you deserve it I don't think you
deserve freedom
sweet tea can suck my dick
you know what you know what I agree I
agree
oh what do you know about tea you threw
it on the [__] River guys come on
[Applause]
[Music]
freedom to
see if that's what if that's what
Freedom tastes like I hate it man
if by free you mean a free trip to the
hospital then yeah sure
oh wait never mind it's not free for you
guys
but at number two
you guys who said drugs who said drugs
hey hey it's north Florida that was that
was a different show okay
that was actually on the board in
Florida I just want to put
but at number two you guys said
food hell yeah which means there is one
thing that is higher than all of these
answers do you go do you think you know
what the answer is
[Applause]
of course you guys know yourselves
because at number one you guys said
guns baby
[Applause]
all right
guys guys I gotta ask at every show we
do guns is on the board but it's not
just guns it's always gun slash violence
what the hell guys not gun slash safety
not gun slash responsible gun slash
violence guys
no don't woo that don't woo that
is it is it that you guys use guns
violently or do you just like violence
look at they like they like violence I
think the answer is yes okay now the
answer is yes
but this next question always gets the
crowd Rowdy because we asked you guys to
name the best fast food chain in the U.S
[Applause]
what are you going first Joey
well just go with your heart
who said Tesco's yes that's that's the
correct answer that is the correct
answer
they don't have that here I know
you know
I'm just gonna go with my heart
all right I'm just gonna go with my
heart and my heart says Chick-fil-A
[Applause]
you know what I say to that
putting Chick-fil-A gone
do you think Chick-fil-A's on the board
Joey hell yeah all right I gotta say
Chick-fil-A has been on almost every
board we've asked so far
hello agree but with the amount of booze
here we might change that yes or you
might be lying which you guys do a lot
so is Chick-fil-A on the board
yes
[Applause]
guys
we get to eat every Sunday am I right
he's not getting back dude help Jared
yeah yeah I I almost don't even want to
get up after that
do we need a crane to like lift you up
Joey are we good guys guys come on
we know what the answer is we don't even
need it why are we even [__] around
with this survey
[Applause]
the best fast food chain in the US
without a doubt
is in and out
[Applause]
it is wait why are you somebody said
Subway are you okay
[Applause]
are you okay
let's try you should try real food for
once
you're eating like cardboard cutout food
bro that ain't food in some way I don't
think I need to ask you guys if this is
on the list but I'm gonna ask you anyway
guys is it on the list
all right it is in and out on the list
of course it is of course guys I knew
you would but that raises the question
what other answers did you guys put
well at number five you guys said
raising games
why are you Brewing that
it's good dude that sauce is nuts it's
so good I don't know if I don't know if
you guys put like cocaine in your sauce
but that [__] slaps dude
God damn so we've booed Chick-fil-A and
raising canes do you guys just hate
chicken is that it
but all right at number four Joey I
think you should have truly followed
your heart what because at number four
it is Wendy
you know what La I take that back that's
pretty good
foreign
at number three though I gotta ask guys
what the actual [__] no what the [__]
guys
because this shows up on almost every
list no and it's the one thing all three
of us agree on and this [__] sucks at
number three
Taco Bell guys no no
no
[Applause]
you have good Mexican food here why are
you putting this on the list nope
I I refuse to believe anyone eats this
sober no way
[Applause]
so
you go to a fast food chain you go for
the [__] drink
oh you know I go to
the but for the vibe you know and the
free Wi-Fi it makes sense yeah makes
sense all right I gotta say though guys
I thought it couldn't get any lower no
what but it does guys it does what it
does I gotta really question your food
uh your food taste if this is at number
two because at number two in America or
you voted as the second best fast food
chain it is
McDonald's
um I'm just leaving I'm leaving
I'm leaving guys guys you've eaten this
right
why would you put it on the board
[Applause]
you know you know you have the worst
McDonald's in the world right in America
right yes
I don't I don't feel safe here I don't
want to come back on bro I ordered a
chicken sandwich and they practically
threw it in the bag like it came
disassembled
how did you [__] that up
no no this this is not this is not worth
a chance start my guy all right oh wait
that means that means though of course
at number one you guys voted in and out
yes
great taste great taste guys
[Applause]
boo Whataburger and you put McDonald's
on the [__] list what a burger
no dude
Whataburger or McDonald's which one
can I have no we have an imposter
where where's the Imposter
[Applause]
I see you I get actually wood you're
gonna run off the stage when you do that
yeah probably all right
all right I'm happy you guys have great
taste thank you all right thank you the
next question though we get to find out
about what you think about your
neighbors because we ask you guys to
name a state you'd hate to be isakai to
now if you don't speak weep isakai means
to be transported or to be reborn in
guys so basically a place you don't want
to end up in
Connor
silence
silence guys shut the [__] up
Jesus whatever schizophrenia bro I'm
just hearing things all right
shut up American
all right
we have gone around the entirety of the
US at this point quite frankly I feel
like I know more about America than all
of you combined
listen
and if there's one there's one thing
that unites the entire us that I've
learned it is a hatred for a specific
State even the state itself hates it and
it's Ohio
all right so so far every state has
voted Ohio as the most hated States
but will you guys comply but for now is
Ohio on the list
of course it is of course it is guys
that means Joey honest taking the
obvious answer what are you gonna go for
well I just hope I keep forgetting
you're in that
I hope and pray that all of you here
tonight look at your siblings
respectfully
no
because wait wait who is booing this who
is booing this
hands up if you're only child
yo there there's not many only children
here guys that was more booze than only
children here that's all I'm saying
should I call an emergency meeting or oh
shut up no but uh yeah I'm hoping that
if you have any siblings you'll look at
your siblings respectfully unlike
Alabama am I right
anyone here from Alabama tonight
what the [__]
so I'm gonna say Alabama bro I I just
figured that was the place where you get
like exiled to in the U.S right
be gone to Alabama all right but is
Alabama on the list
it is it is
now let's find out because we do have an
answer here that has never appeared on
any other survey we've run so far
and that's our number five because at
number five you guys voted
Alaska oh
I heard Alaska was nice I thought I
heard that Alaska was nice
[Music]
it's a cold this is a blood Breeze
there's snow aha oh
but
yeah what is stuff yeah okay
at number four you guys voted Alabama
all right I'll take that or I'll take
that
hell yeah that means there's three slots
left and at number three this is ironic
because I think they put you guys on at
exactly the same spot guys
because
at number three you guys voted
Texas
[Applause]
they put you on the board guys they put
you on the balls yep
[Applause]
all right welcome all right all right so
Ohio is still on the board so I could be
another one or two so Ohio is either
number one or number two one do you guys
think it's at number two no
no do you guys think it's at number one
yes good taste well guys
at number two you guys voted
Florida
all right
if I get it right yes which means yes
everyone hates
Ohio guys
all right guys when I say [__] you say
[__]
[Applause]
being so organized appreciate it that's
the most organized this crowd has been
in the hall now fun fact Ohio also put
Ohio as number one
[Applause]
we're almost at a perfect score for Ohio
we have three shows left after this
they're they're so close they're so
close guys what did they do to the rest
of you guys I just genuinely I don't
know we couldn't be further away from
Ohio and yet the heat continues
but in our next question we get to find
out a little more about the area we're
in because we ask you guys to name
something you think of when you say Los
Angeles
sorry
well and there are
there are some answers here guys that's
all I'm gonna say oh God oh God
um
well if there's one thing definitely
that I think all of us have experienced
a 1.9 lives being here is that holy [__]
your traffic sucks
oh my God
[Music]
did you guys invent traffic
no no they perfected it they perfected
traffic
basically every major city we've been to
have put traffic on the list guys I'm
gonna say that right now but you guys do
it better but did you guys do traffic
better
all right is traffic on the list
[Music]
hell yeah
[Applause]
all right corner
I think about when I say to Los Angeles
Joey took my answer
shut the [__] up
I've already milked him enough
all right
I'm I'm sorry guys all right
this is the one thing that I think about
and I'm so sorry not cocaine
London Does it Better
all right
the one thing I think about when I think
about Los Angeles I'm so sorry don't boo
me you can move me it's fine uh you guys
have so much homeless people
why are you cheering that
[Applause]
why would you cheer that
you're like yeah nobody's got more than
us
I'd rather die than give affordable
housing
yeah are you guys proud of this are you
guys proud of this
what is your chair
do you think it's on a list though do
you think it's on the list
[Applause]
oh my God it is homelessness on the list
[Music]
no way the question is how high though
so guys
at number five of what you said you
think of when you say Los Angeles you
said
famous people of course
influences right guys right guys
like all the like all the tick tock
Stars right guys
[Applause]
[Music]
shut up
butts maybe asking
walk and defeat famous people
well Ludwig
give the man a break
[Applause]
well I'll tell you what can be famous
people at number four guys you guys said
dirty
well
that is uh that is factually correct why
would you guys put this on well because
it is
at uh at number three though of course
this one was obvious guys at number
three you guys said Hollywood of course
which means though why is why are you
booing you put these answers down
my question is why did you guys put
homelessness so high
and traffic that means uh the top two
are either traffic or homelessness now
what do you think is that number one
guys is it
where where is it traffic
[Music]
is it homeless people
oh that was about 50 50.
well guys I believe I'm on point come on
give it to me at number two
you guys
said
homelessness
let's go which means traffic is on top
hell yeah can't get anywhere in this
[__] City
why do you live here
[Applause]
everyone everyone in L.A is like man I
hate this city but I can't leave
what are you gonna go [__] Alabama
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all right
before to leave this is like I think he
can't afford to live here my guy
this seems like the average like life
cycle for an LA person right
question we get to test the weaves in
the crowds
hands up if you're a weeb
hands up if you think you have good
taste
all right all right you guys are pretty
confident we're about to test that right
now because our next question is name
the biggest Giga chart in anime
[Applause]
Corner you're up mate I gotta think I
gotta think I gotta think all right so
so so guys
how how into anime are you guys
you guys big anime fans
like a like a 10
or like a one
I think you
that's not hard to be more of an anime
fan than Joey nowadays listen listen I
think you guys have [__] taste
[Applause]
now normally normally normally we like
to you know we have some of our favorite
guesses for this question now there are
two black Swordsmen in anime that
everyone knows about right
[Applause]
there is the Giga Chad the man himself
guts right
and there's a little beta Kirito right
[Applause]
how are the LA I think you're all
baiters I think your baiters I think
you're I think you have beta taste I
think of [__] tastes in anime so I'm
gonna say Kirito oh hell no
oh so when I'm right you're gonna
pop right
he did not just say that God damn I
think you would put Kirito on the board
God forbid
do you guys have good taste
do you think you'd vote Kirito
[Applause]
all right let's find out is Kirito on
the board
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] taste [__] taste [__] especially
you guys up there even [__] taste
now you know what
you know what La I believe I believe
that although there might be a lot of
people with [__] taste in here there are
some people with great taste as well
[Applause]
so I am going to say on behalf of the
true Black Swordsman guts from berserk
oh
oh okay yeah a cheer for him
yeah and guts isn't on there I don't I'm
gonna jump off the stage do you guys
think guts do you guys think guts is the
true Black Swordsman
all right is God's on the list
[Applause]
[Music]
hold on hold on
where was your love for guts when you
were filling out the form huh seemed
like all the love was going to Carousel
huh
I can't [__] believe I am never
trusting you guys it is you know guys
this is going on YouTube they're gonna
know that you have [__] taste
[Applause]
cannot believe that I gotta say guys
this is um
this is a list
this is a goddamn list but
at number five though I gotta say I'm
pretty surprised this is on the board uh
because this is actually a very Niche
character one that only fellow isekai
Trashmen would know about guys so no I
feel right at home right now guys
because at number five you guys said
anos
hands up if you have no idea who that is
no clue I have no idea who that is oh my
God there's so many there there's so
many that know wow I'm genuinely
surprised
apparently he's a bigger chat than guts
number four though I'm also pretty
surprised this is on the list because at
number four you guys put
Sakamoto oh
good taste pretty good guys all right
you know you're anime some of you know
your eyes you haven't watched Sakamoto
watch it yeah hilarious I still don't
forgive you for putting not putting guts
on there
at number three though
the isakai train continues guys oh the
isakai train continues but but here's
the thing
it's not Kirito guys
it's not Kirito are you [__] seeing
Kirito's in the top two yes Kirito is in
the top too because at number three you
guys voted
cosuma
[Applause]
whoa he literally steals pants he's just
a pervert
[Applause]
that's not a role model
you say he's just like me FBI right over
there there he is the one who's been
taking all the pants
but that means Kirito is at number one
or number two
either way my disappointment is
immeasurable can I just say can I just
say that you know Utah they put guts on
the board
they put guts on the board is Utah
better than California
[Applause]
Ohio put cuts on the board as well guys
come on come on what's your excuse huh
[Music]
see your normies
do you have faith in yourselves now
do you think Curie says at number two
do you think Kirito's at number one
why
okay
I gotta say though guys this is possibly
the worst top two in uh that we've had
in any show that we've done so far
because
at number two
you guys said
Goku
[Applause]
really excuse me guys guys really excuse
me
you're [__] with us all right you're
[__] you got to be [__] with us which
means at number one the biggest Giga
chart in anime is Euro
oh
all right hands up who did it who put
Kirito on the list who did it oh this oh
suddenly there's not many of you oh I
only see a few hands I thought you guys
would be lying how many alt accounts do
you have
okay okay I wish it was rigged for your
sake
okay I gotta I gotta say though guys I
gotta say regardless of Kirito I thought
you said yeah I thought you said you
actually watched anime why is Goku on
the list guys
why is Goku on the list not a big not a
bigger chat
what the [__] is this listed
but
you may notice that there is an extra
space on the board now what's that you
may be wondering what that is well a lot
of you guys filled out the list some of
you guys seriously some of you guys
really stupidly okay yeah I I can uh you
even I can I can tell I can tell even
more easily in this so we're about to
expose one of you guys because there is
a wild card answer that these two are
going to have to guess so it's just one
of the stupidest answers it's one of the
stupidest answers
and because it's so out there if they
guess it they get 10 points
okay all right okay okay
so can you like give us a clue some clue
just to point them in the right
direction sure sure
it's a JoJo reference
[Applause]
A Jojo reference not a character I said
reference
that narrowed it down
um
is it the uh do you I I thought it could
be that is it the uh president of the
United States
do you guys think it's a president of
the United States
is that the world God answer
it's not
Joey another chance is it Jesus
[Applause]
is a canonical character in one of the
parts of Jojo I'm I'm not kidding yeah I
completely forgot about this as is the
president of the United States so yeah
great great manga but is it Jesus
it is not damn Utah would have answered
that
for the Wild Card answer one of you guys
puts
the to be continued Arrow
what oh of course
[Applause]
of course I could get that character of
course it is yeah of course of course
who put this answer down
you're very proud of yourself for this
one
what a [__] answer
what a [__] list but for the next
question we're going to continue
exposing you guys because we asked you
guys to name something that might be in
your search history
all right Joey
all right I gotta I gotta get a feel for
this crowd here okay all right get a
feel get a feel how many of you
are degenerates
[Applause]
how many of you are degenerates that
don't use incognito mode
[Applause]
okay yeah NSA already knows the porn I
watch yeah then uh I I believe the
answer is obvious
you guys
you guys are horny on me and searching
up porn aren't you
I know you can be quiet I know though
you can be quiet all you want why isn't
among us talking about porn
very strange
talking about regular Pawn obviously are
you guys searching our porn
a lot more quiet this time is Pawn on
the list
it is of course it is why are you
surprised who was surprised but Connor
what do you think honor Jerry's taking
the obvious one probably just how to
frame pictures of Kirito or some [__] I
don't know
you put them on the list guys I'm not
forgetting that the rest of the show
okay
um [__] I don't know well that's the
obvious answer right
awesome
you are not Googling Jesus do not lie to
me
all right all right all right
I think you're Googling because you know
you all you all came here today I think
I want to have a bit of an ego for a
second I think maybe you're searching up
yeah trash taste right
you guys searching up trash taste
[Applause]
what you
you guys really weren't sure about that
one porn you were like yeah trash day no
I'm tired give it an audience I don't
want to hear it I don't want your cheers
actually [__] them all right let's find
out then is trash taste on the list
[Music]
I love you guys predictable all of you
the real question is what's higher Pawn
or trash taste trash taste I believe
trash taste we're about to find out
because at number five you guys said
Chris brought
[Applause]
stop feeding his ego okay
we are absolutely not showing this video
to Chris no we are not we are not we're
changing this we're changing this in the
edit yeah at number four though I think
you guys took this a little bit too
literally because at number four you
guys said
food nearby
[Applause]
I hope you guys found your answers I
hope you guys have actually had dinner
okay before coming to the show man's
Gotta Eat dude man's got it
who hasn't eaten yet
all right we'll all go to In and Out
after right
all right at number three though
of course you guys like anime rights
because you put that on the list every
one's a weep here yep which means oh
we're one or two all right which means
porn or trash taste is your number one
search history come on porn you have the
wholesome monster trash taste and you
have the degenerate answer come on
are you guys wholesome
[Music]
are you guys degenerates
all right let's find out if you're lying
because why at number two you guys said
trash days
which means of course guys we honest be
horny as [__] it's number one let's go
hell yeah horny on me in La let's go
but
we're about to find out just how horny
you guys are
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry I completely
missed the Wild Card answer for that let
me let me go back a bit because there is
a wild card answer for the search
history uh and I think I blanked on this
because this makes absolutely no sense
right it's a sentence Oh fantastic okay
and it is six words
and I'll give you the first three words
guys I'll give you the first three words
because the first three words are can a
cow
foreign
[Music]
I gotta count the words hold on
can a cow
eat another cow
wait what
I don't [__] know they searched up
Chris broad what do you think
do you think someone's into cow
cannibalism dude that's a question I
want answered as well is the wild God
can a cow eat a cow
of course it's not
um I'm gonna go with uh can a cow
kick Goku's ass
[Applause]
yo top 10 characters that can be Goku
cows all right is it can a cow beat up
kick Goku's ass
it's not okay so I gotta ask who the
hell searched this because the Wild Card
answer is
can a cow go upstairs backwards
[Applause]
who who
searched this
who searched this
is
you right there did you find out the
answer
great great well thank you for filling
out our form oh
now we're all wondering the more
important question is why were you
searching this
[Applause]
oh
thanks for that
sometimes your spiritual fans am I right
all right but moving on to the final
question as I said we're about to find
out just how horny you guys are because
we asked you guys to name a hentai
category you secretly like
[Applause]
silence oh my God you silence you guys
are so horny oh my God all right all
right
now the question is do you have good
taste
no no you put Kirito I don't know if I
should trust you
how [__] up are your tastes
yeah
I'd like to think that
a lot of you shut the [__] up about
orimo
I'd like to think that a lot of you feel
similarly to me in many ways
and I think I think hold on I want to go
get something I want to I want to go and
get something real quick
oh where are you going we've got a gift
from a fan today hold my mic for a
second God
all right what is it what is that are
you gonna wear it he's gonna change his
shirt
[Applause]
all right
my answer is MILFs
[Applause]
do you guys also like MILFs
it's MILFs on the board
[Music]
[Applause]
is there uh just out of curiosity is
there any mums in the crowd right now
I'll see you later
well Joey
what are you gonna say Joey well
if there's one thing we've learned is
that this crowd cannot be trusted
and although
you guys answered a certain thing in a
certain question previously I'd like to
believe the irony is real of the fact
that you aren't looking at your siblings
respectfully
well they wouldn't they wouldn't you
wouldn't you wouldn't so I think you
horny [__] put incest up there
didn't you oh
why are some people cheering
that's no no I pray to God you're an
only child
well we we did the count earlier and
there weren't many of you so I'm going
to be very worried if this is on the
list guys oh God so
is incest on the list
[Music]
guys what the [__]
this
is that is that why you put Alabama on
the list guys you wish you were them you
wish you could go to Alabama you hate
them because you ain't them is that it
is that it
but
let's find out
because
at number five you guys said
futa and
um
hey you know what that's pretty good
taste no no because uh normally this
one's a lot higher guys normally this
one's at number one sure I think this is
the lowest we've ever seen future
come on guys step it up but you may be
wondering
what is that number four guys
well at number four you guys said
vanilla
[Applause]
foreign
you put it down it's your list why I I
like to think this is like the real
hardcore DeGeneres that are like well I
don't want to seem too Normie but you
know I kind of like this [__] so I'll
just put it on why is incest higher like
I gotta say guys most other states put
futa and vanilla as the top two guys
because guys because normally uh
normally it doesn't get more degenerate
as we go higher but this is definitely
true for this list you guys definitely
wouldn't put incest higher than MILF
right you wouldn't do it you wouldn't
put incest higher than MILF right
please
well
at number three please please you guys
said
incest
which is why he clapping
which
which means guys number one number one
MILF is either one number one one or
number two one
why would you say two
shut up do you guys think MILF is that
number two
do you guys think MILF is that number
one
yes yes
well guys
at number two
you guys said
mouth
wait wait wait which means what's higher
than MILF which means there is one
hentai category what has beaten up or
that has beaten MILF sorry
no no no no ah no please please uh
number one
these are three letters I never like to
say guys
because at number one you guys voted
[Applause]
why
no
shout out to the people who have no idea
what half these words mean they're doing
great don't don't answer your search
history do not do not search this
ah [__] taste Kirito and NC I don't want
to do like getting cucked
thank you thank you I was so angry it's
okay
what could be worse than NTR
but
um
guys just to top it off we have a
[__] wild card on so
um I'm trying to figure out how to give
a hint for this world God answer because
uh number one it's not a hentai category
guys
at least I really really hope it's not
um what
it is
a seafood
I'm sorry I'm sorry could you repeat
that
it is a seafood it is uh is it is it a
blowfish
you think it's a blowfish yeah
is the Wild Card answer a blue fish
it is not
I tried guys uh uh
I don't want to imagine any Seafood in
any situation like this
uh
uh oysters
[Music]
what do you think is you think it's
oysters or oysters how the [__] would
you sexualize that
I don't know how the [__] would you
sexualize a blowfish Connor I assume it
could blow do you guys think it's
oysters
[Music]
is the Wild Card hamster oysters
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh no no no no no hold on hold on hold
on hold on I appreciate the chant but
who the [__] put this up here
I need to talk to your parents
yeah so it's it's oysters clams mussels
so what oh wow so what what
sorry say it all again
okay just in case okay just in case you
didn't hear that she said I work in an
oyster Factory and I make them come
[Applause]
um
well good for you I guess I I ain't ever
eating Seafood with you my guy is that
like a master class for this is it like
is that what you say on a first date
it's like I'll have you know I can make
him come or order the oysters just see
what happens
[Laughter]
oh my God I can't believe I [__] God
wait do I get [__] by that but that is
the end of the game oh
and come on the score stand up
with the Wild Card guess Joey has 29
Points
that's high that's pretty high
and corner
[Applause]
yes
which means Joey loses again and has to
do another punishment bring out the
punishment wheel
I made you suffer twice now yeah I mean
[__] do I do I have to spin it now while
I'm doing this yeah you're gonna spin it
now Joe all right and be among us call
stream all right are you guys ready
all right here we go three two one spin
the wheel
[Music]
oh oh no oh no no no no
no I spit again wait spin it again wait
what Joy hold on I can't I can't see
what is it little baby man the gotcha
Gods Must Be On Your Side because you
got loser picks for winner
[Applause]
suck a dick
thank God why did I bother winning
what's the point in winning if I don't
have to [__] well then what should I
make what do you think
[Applause]
none of them none of them right well you
know
I've heard from certain sources that
Connor you have a beautiful singing
voice
and so I think we are in the perfect
situation where you guys want to hear
him sing the national anthem don't you
[Applause]
foreign
ER you did say that you know America
better than the crowd so you're about to
prove it Connor just how American are
you I'm definitely not Googling the
lyrics because I don't know them
all right
[__] well ladies and Gentlemen please
stand for your national anthem
[Applause]
I do not want to do this I think your
national anthem is okay it's fine I
don't really like it that much I can't
sing
all right Connor are you ready
fine fine yeah sure fine all right oh
can you see [__] by the dawn's early
lies what's so probably weed hail at the
twilight's last
rhyme said what is this right
[Music]
that's me and the rockets
the bombs bursting in
gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there oh say does the
Star Spangled
Banner yet wave
[Music]
and the home of the bread
[Applause]
wow are you it's true Connor you have a
great singing voice oh
I don't know
I will say the last part does go hard
all right it does you do feel free I
gotta say guys does this feel like a
fever dream for you guys
you guys know what British people are
supposed to be doing okay
you get to see uh Connor and Among Us
and a banana waving an American flag
singing the national anthem
awful awful
speaking of which though my time is up I
must get out yes Jerry is now free from
the among us we're out of Applause for
being in that sauna
I am I'm never singing this ever again
after the tour
why would I
I gotta say that guys I think after this
tour I think I know more words to your
national anthem than my own
the English one doesn't have that many
words to remember it's very easy
then it's just I've never sung here but
it's just God saved the king over and
over again right it's [__] it's so lazy
that's why the Welsh one is way better
it's about killing English people it's
sick
no no we've already had one Google it
oh no no no no no no
[Applause]
listen
if I fold it to peer pressure I'd be an
American [__] that no no
no
all right
we also don't have the assets ready so
we can't do it
but yeah that was the second game guys
enjoy that
oh wow it's so nice to actually see your
faces yeah how does it feel you're
sweating so much bro I came out of that
a manga suit and I look like you know
when Aaron first comes out as a Titan
it's just like steam it's like
it's [__] horrible but it is time for
the third and final round and the host
for this is me
now
this last game is my personal favorite
because I feel it perfectly embodies the
spirit of trash taste because you guys
will hopefully know and have watched
this enough to know that uh here on
trash taste we make some opinions
some are good mine
and others are corners
mine are great
so and you know when we see them on
trash taste right we we you guys type up
your angry comments you put them up on
the subredd and we see it five weeks
later and we go oh [__] probably
shouldn't have said that
but tonight you guys are here with us
live
and uh
if you ask me I don't think we should
let them get away with this
so welcome to the final part of the show
which is called the trash taste Court
[Music]
I gotta get some equipment back here
because this is gonna be a doozy all
right so let's bring back everyone's
crowd favorite
the boy damn he's thick
can you believe us guys that we have
managed to take all of the opinions that
have been said in past trash taste
episodes and fit them all into one trash
can
literally impossible
it would look like a New York this
sidewalk this thing is dense
but
inside of here is a bunch of opinions
that all three of us have made and it is
up to both Connor and Grant to pick out
one of those opinions at random from
this box and whoever pulls out the
opinion regardless of if it's their own
opinion my opinion Conor's opinion gun
spinning doesn't matter they have to
argue for that opinion
wait so I might have to argue
God's opinion I'm not arguing you know
what [__] your feelings
it's up to church
how am I going to argue food poisoning
is not an illness how do you begin to
argue that but as the judge of today I
have here the trash taste gavel
this is where our entire budget went
looks weighty do you guys want to hear
it
[Applause]
oh
Hefty and so I will be the judge for
today but if you know anything about
court cases you'll know that you know
there's a little thing called the jury
and uh wow look how many jury members
there are today
there's a lot of you so you guys will be
playing along as the jury to decide who
is guilty and who is not guilty with the
aid of this little contraption that we
have built you guys want to give it a
little spin
[Music]
okay guys let's let's test this out can
I get a chair if you like bone-in
chicken
no no
boneless chicken
[Applause]
yes yes
I'm already disappointed I'm already
disappointed but
we should probably get started you guys
ready
all right we should do rock paper
scissors to decide yeah what's the rock
paper scissors to decide who pulls out
on three or after three
one two on three on three on three one
two three
you got to go first all right so gone no
matter what you pull out of trash box
can hear you have to argue for it you
have one minute to uh give your argument
to the jury let's see if they will
listen they're so deep the reason you
don't want to go first is because our
opinions suck
all right
all right whose opinion is it
it's your opinion
wait that means I have to argue against
my own opinion that means you have to
argue against your own opinion gone read
out the opinion out loud You Should Skip
video game cutscenes
gameplay but you can skip the cutscene
how
how am I even going to begin without you
guys just booing immediately this this
is
wait wait
I just give up I wish I could man
my God are you ready to give your
opinion okay I I think I think I'm ready
LA are you ready
so I like to hear God you have one
minute on the clock here we go three two
one
okay guys hear me out okay no no guys
guys guys guys guys hear me out okay
because you know me I do like my story
okay but there is one video game where I
think it's perfectly okay to give to
skip card scenes okay and I have two
words for you genjin impact
look look look he may skip cutscenes
because he hates story I skipped cut
scenes because I hate buy mono right
like if I lived here if I have to hear
pie one's voice one more time I think
I'm just gonna end it all guys
look all I'm saying is pymon [__]
sucks and that's once again it's give
God these guys
thank you very much
why are you cheering for that
don't agree with that opinion
I don't know man that was a very strong
opinion I must say but Connor you're on
the opposition you have to argue against
your own opinion for one minute
so I gotta so I gotta argue that story
in video games is good yes yes yes and
that you shouldn't skip them
okay okay yeah good okay you got it I
think so all right Ellie are you ready
all right Connor one minute on the clock
three two one
um why stop
I like the story in the video games
um I think it enhances the video game uh
I like the the cutscenes in League of
Legends
um
I like the uh the story of jump King
right it's a good story right
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm playing the
game aren't I
oh oh don't play a [__] story again I
don't give a [__] all right
I have a great time okay
um I love stories in video games
um uh uh Elden ring has a story right I
don't know what it is
it's probably a great story right about
dodging the bosses I I don't know the
true signals do listen okay I don't pay
much attention but I'm sure it's good
right
[__] you guys
wow I have a feeling this is gonna be a
close argument
but
it is not up to me to decide it is up to
you guys the jury to decide who won that
argument so let's start and remember if
you disagree with someone it's totally
okay to be silent booing just adds to
this all right so we we like silence
here at trustees well you guys are very
good at it already all right
so
Los Angeles can you shout as loud as you
can if you agree with Connor's opinion
[Music]
what the [__]
this is your opinion
La shout as loud as you can if you agree
with God's opinion
stop
oh
the only people that can Cloud on
genshin players more is genjin players
guys
all right all right should we play Let's
go to the second one you don't rock
paper scissors again yeah three one two
one
[Music]
easy
all right oh my God once again I'm Gonna
Change next time it's time to pull out
an opinion and remember no matter what
it is you have to argue for it God damn
you're getting deep you're like double
cheeks I'm getting a full view yeah boys
how's the view going how's the video
stop how's the view guys how's the view
get the opinion out already all right
whose opinion is a first of all I can't
believe I got this opinion what it's
your opinion Joy read it out loud
why didn't I get this opinion
there are no good modern anime
yeah I I don't know who said that but uh
yeah who said that Joey who said yeah
yeah who said that yeah I wonder who
said that uh excuse you my name is Josh
the manga ladder I get a ride
guys how dare you assume you're allowed
to cheer or boo during the argument by
the way just keep that in mind yeah you
guys can boo what you're as loud as you
can during the argument all right all
right boss Let's Do It come on one
minute on the clock are you ready I
can't believe the one who actually
watches anime gets this one
are you ready
I'd like to hear God you have one minute
on the clock here we go three
one
guys do you know why modern anime sucks
because I watch it all right amen that's
how you know it sucks all right man let
me tell you about my favorite anime
domestic girlfriend guys
this sucks it sucks run to girlfriend
guys
so sucks
um or emo guys
also sucks like why are you cheering I'm
literally naming the worst anime of all
time guys
look look all I'm saying is if you watch
isakai like me you know that modern
anime sucks guys amen all right amen
look that's why you put Kirito first on
the [__] list amen all right you know
we don't have good taste in anime guys
it sucks oh
God
damn God why did you guys try for [__]
anime
I didn't even have to pay for that guys
that's free content for me all right I
got this all right Connor I got this it
is up to you now to argue against this
opinion are you ready very ready LA are
you ready
all right here we go one minute on the
clock three two one
guys
Jojo
[Applause]
part two
two part three
[Applause]
JoJo part
four
what about JoJo Part Five Guys we like
that one
but JoJo part six right
let's list off some other Classics you
know we had cyberpunk Edge Runners
recently right
also change someone is airing right now
and it's
it's good so how can you say that about
modern anime how can you say it sucks
we've had some of the best anime we've
ever had
anime fans are eating good
all right arcane
guys guys he said anime
watch arcane
don't let me get the gavel out on you I
will
but
but jury it is time for you guys to
decide Avatar's a good show
it's time for you guys to decide though
who is the winner so
you guys ready to shout
yeah all right
can I get a big loud chair if you agree
with God's opinion
[Music]
my man why my guy right there right
there oh but uh can you shout as loud as
you can if you guys Connor's opinion
your taste great taste
well
yeah it is interesting now I I think uh
I think it's unfair though right grant
had to argue that right and that's
that's not yeah yeah I'm the one who
actually watches anime so I know modern
anime is good I think Joey should argue
the opinion as well right
[Applause]
the anime man needs to tell us why
modern anime sucks Joey right yeah come
on we have to listen to you right you're
an authority figure okay are you serious
yes yes come on
come on Joey Joey get on stage Joey
it's really Bittersweet you're chanting
because I know you're immediately about
to boo me
all right Joey please tell us why modern
anime sucks in three
two one
all right you know what [__] it [__] it
I'm gonna be real with you all you guys
are talking about a chainsaw man right
there's only been two episodes how do
you know it's good
you guys are really confident about one
direct priority when that came out that
really ended up well didn't it
too soon too soon also I'm sorry I'm
kind of [__] sick of seeing the same
isakai [__] protagonist story over
and over and over again
[Music]
it's [__]
give me something good
all came
joy joy
I I I can't watch this anymore man this
is this is painful I got I got I'm
telling me I got asked you man to man
brother to brother do you actually still
agree with this opinion
oh what a flake what a flag Joe come on
man come on if there's a time to be
honest man it's it's okay it's okay to
be wrong Joey it's okay to be wrong man
no
all right you know what you know what
I think you owe a YouTuber style apology
video to this crowd guys
go ahead not just anybody a YouTuber
hold on let me let me let me set up real
quick let me set up deep breaths um
we're in La home of the YouTuber
Technologies does anyone have a dog here
I need a pet you can you can have a
banana dog oh okay
all right
all right all right silence he's about
to apologize this is a rat feed on trash
taste just pretend this is a dog
I have made a serious lapse of judgment
guys
I uh what I said back then does not
reflect who I am today
cry cry
what
I'm sorry man worth
I and you know and now that I've been
given this opportunity I'm gonna say it
right now
chainsaw man is [__] amazing
[Applause]
I got a lie Round of Applause for the
apology
God damn it
well
with that public execution out of the
way it's time for the final round and
it's really interesting guys gaunt and
Connor both have one point each so this
is the tiebreaker yes all right all
right which one of you is going first
you know what I'm gonna do right
one two three
all right hold on I will I will I will
judge over this I will judge over this
we've got some audible say it three two
one right okay okay ready three two one
go
wait God
I got he fell for it again yes yes
[Applause]
what do you what are you five years old
did you actually believe him I changed
it and then I changed it back all right
pull out that last one I can't believe
this God's just guys just agreeing with
everything today
all right did you just like Darren Brown
me with that I swear to God I can't your
third and final opinion that you have to
argue for first of all whose opinion is
it it's uh my one oh
yeah this should be easy for you this
should be easy for you right this is
this is going to be this is uh easy oh
are you [__]
you're so [__] uh would you like to
read it out loud all bread tastes the
same
so if you don't know gone famously said
that he thinks all bread legitimately
tastes the same yeah
so he's gonna argue that for you guys
well gone
you are about to do something uh very
brave
you are about to argue in front of a
thousand Americans that all bread tastes
the same
oh
well I'm gonna ask
Egon is are you ready
yes yes yes
I'm ready all right LA are you ready
one minute on the clock gone
good [__] luck three two one
guys guys guys guys guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys let me just say let me
just say
there must be someone in the audience
that hates Pizza grass like me guys
there must be I hear you I see you okay
you know what I'm gonna say it I'm gonna
say it all bread does taste the same you
know what I care about
you know what I care about the filling
guys The Filling it's all about the you
think if I order a sandwich I care about
what type of brand I choose no no you
think when I eat a pizza I want to eat
the [__] crust of that [__] yes no no
give me the pizza okay that just takes
up space all I'm saying is I just hate
bread okay now I said it I said it it's
on camera it's on camera
why did you throw he didn't even throw
that's that was just what he really
thinks even even Atlas couldn't carry
that argument
well with that out of the way Connor
um tell me another story I have to argue
you have to if I if I have this correct
you have to argue against that opinion
okay you have to convince them that no
all bread doesn't actually taste the
same can you do that
I believe in you you ready I'm ready you
guys ready LA are you ready let's do it
third and final arguments one minute on
the clock Connor three two one
second let me go and get something guys
let me go get something you know I've
I've learned a lot from this tour I've
learned an awful lot where is this oh
here it is I've learned so much from
this tour and one of the main things
that I've learned from this tour is that
you know we British people we don't have
taste buds but you guys
you guys have taste buds right right
[Music]
thank you
you guys know the difference between
bread you know how good that [__] is
right
you eat your pizza crust right
we know that all bread does not taste
the same because we have taste buds
right
[Applause]
Los Angeles you have great [__] taste
um
[Applause]
sorry I'll I'll hold this to you guys
I was making a dramatic argument okay
well with that out of the way guys it is
time for you to to decide which one of
these two is going to go home with the w
let's find out
I wonder who it's gonna be
so
Ellie can you shout as loud as you can
if you agree with God's opinion
[Music]
hey my fellow Pizza grass haters I hear
you man I hear you go back to daycare
well
finally I would like to ask you all to
chat as loud as you can if you agree
with Connor's opinion
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen with that out of
the way the winner of today's trash
taste court is the monkey boy
[Applause]
thank you which means that it is time
God for you to do your punishment all
right bring up the punishment wheel Joey
no no no no no no no no no
this is the last game of this show and
uh the punishment wheel will not do for
you
so I want you to go backstage oh again
again one more time
but that was the third and final game
guys you enjoy that
I love I love this trash taste cord
because I just love seeing these two
just copium for like three minutes at a
time I love not getting sweaty but here
I am making those arguments is tough my
voice is gone uh aren't you glad the
[__] orange argument didn't come up
you would have been massacred but it's
not that did not go down well in Florida
yeah he had he had this opinion in
Florida and uh he had to argue that you
know orange was the worst flavor I have
never heard that many angry Floridians
in my life trying to storm the stage yes
it was impressive
oh my God I'm excited to see kant's new
outfit though you guys excited ladies
and gentlemen
it's clown
foreign
[Applause]
oh my God how do you feel God
I I don't feel good Connor you look
great do I look great just listen to
this guys
[Music]
but guys that is the end of the trash
Taste show did you guys enjoy it
we had an awesome time as well but I
think the final thing that we should all
do together is take a selfie
yeah let's do it let's do it all right
guys I want to see the best Jojo poses
out of all of you guys are you guys
ready all right everybody all right can
we turn the lights on
all right smile guys do your best poses
[Music]
thank you guys so much appreciate it Los
Angeles thank you very much for coming
out tonight you guys were [__]
awesome thank you thank you so much
if you still want to get merges still
available guys but thank you very much
for being an amazing audience guys give
it up
[Applause]
I've been Connor I've been gone and I've
been Joey and we've been trash days good
night everybody
bye
[Music]